bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
nous sommes ici au coeur du parlement
européen à bruxelles
et nous allons consacrer toute cette
émission à la polémique autour des
expulsions de roms par la france et nous
irons en roumanie à bucarest pour voir
comment la population rom et traités sur
place et si les programmes européens
fonctionnent mais tout de suite une
question elle est posée par nora ahmadi
les roms sont ils des citoyens européens
comme les autres c'est l'équivalent du
28ème état de l'union et celui là n'est
pas prêt d'intégrer le clan fermé des
européens
tiens les roms c'est 10 à 12 millions
d'âmes la plus grande minorité de lieux
mais aussi la plus pauvre la moins
éduquées la plus discriminée
on les a découverts contre la roumanie a
postulé au club de l'europe
il a donc fallu montrer patte blanche et
prouver qu'on faisait beaucoup de choses
pour les aider à s'intégrer et à se
sédentariser même bruxelles a mis les
moyens
17 milliards et demi d'euros ont été
budgétés entre 2007 et 2013 beaucoup
d'argent alors qu at-on fait de tous ses
sous pas grand chose d'après la
commission européenne sur 2 milliards
d'euros mise à disposition la roumanie
n'en n'a utilisé que 38 millions la
france elle n'utilise pas ces fonds
européen plutôt que de contrôler l'usagé
de ces enveloppes et mettre en oeuvre
des politiques globales l'europe
convoque des sommets sur la question
cette année c'était à cordoue en espagne
à la fin ce fut comme toujours une belle
déclaration
les roms sont des citoyens comme les
autres il faut les respecter ne pas les
discriminer
bah tiens donc cet été en france on a
décidé de les renvoyer en masse en
europe de l'est ces citoyens européens
l'italie aussi voudrait pouvoir ramener
tout ce beau monde dans leur pays comme
bon lui semble alors l'europe les roms
les citoyens comme les autres
alors les roms sont ils des citoyens
européens comme les autres vernis de
keyser bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation quand on voit
l'attitude de certains pays ces
dernières semaines et en particulier
l'attitude du gouvernement français
on peut douter effectivement que les
roms soient considérés comme des
citoyens européens
du point de vue de la législation
européenne c'est clair ce sont des
citoyens comme les autres mais d un
groupe vulnérable
aujourd'hui c'est devenu un groupe
expulsables donc là il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé alors peut-être
simplement porté à vous avez cité la
france vous citer les autres pays je
pense que en général au niveau de
l'union européenne
il y a effectivement des discriminations
à l'égard des roms et aidera on n'a pas
fait la politique d'accueil qu on aurait
dû faire pas tenté en tout cas de les
sortir de la pauvreté
mais au niveau de l'italie dans le passé
au niveau de la france
on a franchi à mon ami un pas
supplémentaire c'est à dire c'est à dire
quelque chose qui les a jetés en pâture
à l'opinion publique
ça y est on est dans une situation
économique difficile
on fait des coupes dans tous les budgets
et puis on vous jette
j'ai dit jeter en pâture parce que moi
j'avais été frappé cet été de voir
bond hortefeux en parlant aux débuts de
la sphère des roms par aller où
montrer des les voitures qui tiraient
les caravanes et puis j'ai retrouvé les
mêmes photos dans la presse en belgique
et je pense que quand on commence à
montrer des mercedes qui tire des
caravanes et en dix ans et cela
finalement
regardez comment ils vivent on va très
très loin est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec la les comparaisons qui avait fait
madame reding par exemple la commissaire
européenne quand elle disait elle a pas
dit regrettant comme ça mais en gros il
a dit ça me fait un peu penser à ce qui
se passait pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale mais tout à fait mais tout à
fait et sur le fond sur la forme parce
que d'abord madame reding n'a pas
assimilé le gouvernement français aux
nazis elle a rappelé deux choses 1
les tziganes comme les homosexuels comme
les communistes mais ça c'était les
prisonniers politiques comme les juifs
aient eu en masse ont été dans les camps
de concentration
c'est tout de même pas un détail de
l'histoire c est ce qu on peut comparer
des personnes qui sont ramenées chez
elles dans leur pays
on est les gens qui a déporté pour lire
les noms sont représentés mais il faut
comparer je vous pose la question mais
elle n'a pas comparer il a dit on n'a
plus vu ça depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale ils ont été discriminés à
l'époque et c'est à partir de la seconde
guerre mondiale qu'on a décidé et en
créant l'europe qu'il n'y aurait plus de
discrimination à rennes par la race par
le groupe ethnique etc
donc on ne peut pas confisquer
l'histoire comme ça c'est à partir de là
que la démonstration a été faite que
contenait et tient compte de l'ethnie de
la race on peut arriver à des
débordements qu'on ne peut pas contrôler
et donc je trouve comme madame reding a
eu raison mais à l'arrêt la paille à la
maison sur le fond et sur la forme
également et elle avait raison sur la
forme parce que madame rémy est
intervenu coûté très petit des très
petits rappels madame reding avait été
interpellé
avant ces paroles fameuse et les gammes
interpellé par le parlement syrien se
transposera second et nous l'avons
également injurié la pauvre je m'en
souviens même et elle a défendu la
france et elle a dit on ne peut pas
attaquer un état sans preuve
vous pensez bien que j'ai eue les
représentants français cette règle n'est
donné l'assurance qu'il ne visait pas
les rom et/ou si je n'ai pas de fait je
n'attaquerai pas
et puis elle tombe sur la circulaire et
à ce moment là
évidemment elle se fait le porte parole
du parlement qui avait voté une
résolution demandant l'expulsion des
roms dont il ya tout un passé
parlementaire toute impasse et
d'interpellation et madame reding dit
non depuis la guerre on discrimine plus
en fonction de la soutenait qu'est ce
qu'on pense et je trouve qu'elle abrite
qu'est-ce que penser de l'attitude
française depuis quelques mois à propos
de ce dossier
est-ce que vous pensez que la france est
en train de soi décrédibiliser l'europe
soit de se décrire divisé en europe la
france
je ne parlerai pas de la france le
gouvernement français joue un jeu très
dangereux et il a joué ici il est il
joue un jeu très dangereux dont deux
domaines d'abord j'étais interloqué par
votre débat sur l'identité nationale
pourquoi et bien entendu on a tu
l'identité mais les identités elles sont
multiples on le sait on est européen en
même temps comme français en même temps
comme breton on n'abandonne pas émis
deux entités pour une autre reprendre le
thème de l'identité nationale alors
qu'il ya une montée des mouvements de
droite et d'extrême droite qui utilise
ça partout en europe c'est jouer avec le
feu et aujourd'hui retour à ce set ce
problème identitaire attaque
véritablement sur le côté ethnique des
roms c'est très très dangereux et la
mort en ce 7 août sort il le fait pour
des raisons que j'ignore les raisons
probablement d'instrumentalisation mais
moi je ne me pose pas sur le plan de la
politique interne français je me pose
sur le plan de ce que représente pour
nous la france la france est un grand
pays d'eymet
t à partir du moment où le grand pays
des libertés joue de cette manière là
mais écoutez ce qui est à dieu on avait
critiqué berlusconi la france le fait
demain un autre petit pays où il ya des
mouvements d'extrême droite et les
partis d'extrême droite qui arrivait au
pouvoir
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils s'en priverait
alors moi j'entends j'entends tout le
monde j'ai entendu hubert védrine à lyon
ce week-end
hilbert vydrine de relais de risque de
la dilution de l'identité du jeu que
devait jouer la france dans l axe
franco-allemand dans l'europe
moi je veux bien moi je veux bien dans l
axe franco allemand
mais attention à ce moment là est la
manière dont jours merci beaucoup
véronique de keyser pour cette analyse
alors l'attitude de la france envers les
roms a été à bande armée damman
commentées par nos voisins européens et
par les télévisions européennes bien sûr
voici un florilège rassembler pour nous
par cécile 6e pour réagir à vif sur les
propos de viviane reding
la bbc avait réuni sur son plateau des
députés européens et autres manches
on salue l'aplomb de la vice présidente
de la commission
je suis ici depuis onze ans et je n'ai
jamais vu une commissaire faire un
discours comme celui là c'est un
discours extraordinaire par rapport à ce
que les commissaires ont l'habitude de
dire cela envoie un signal très fort à
tout autre pays qui voudrait faire la
même chose
italiens eux relèvent les tics de
langage du président jeu pendant la
conférence de presse le président a
exprimé son point de vue en utilisant au
moins une douzaine de fois le mot
outrage et dans toutes ses déclinaisons
s'il a martelé certains mots son
discours était pourtant bien ficelé pour
ses chroniqueurs de la télévision belge
jugé trice parfaitement toutes les
techniques modernes de la propagande
on a soigné un débat est haut plus on
parle de ce débat au plus c'est efficace
pour sarkozy dont la protestation
européenne c'est une aubaine pour lui
même le front national n'aurait pas rêvé
un tel scénario
outre-rhin la presse a été très critique
sur la sortie de nicolas sarkozy ce
journaliste allemand commandes
d'ailleurs l'humeur du président
français électeurs cherchent pas noreen
loup les tensions étaient surtout
palpable du côté de nicolas sarkozy
après les attaques de la commission
européenne
il s'est dit plus que blessé une
brouille largement commentée par la
presse européenne extrêmement sévère à
l'égard des alors nous avons été rejoint
par lorenzo consoli bonjour alors vous
êtes président de l'association de la
presse internationale
ici à bruxelles vous êtes donc
journalistes européens présents ici à
bruxelles depuis 20 ans vous avez vu un
petit peu les reportages convient de
voir sur la façon justement dont le
dossier la polémique des roms était
perçu un peu partout en europe
comment ça a été perçu ici à bruxelles
par la presse internationale je crois
que
il y a surtout un problème concernant la
réaction française compte il ya eu
madame reding qui a fait ce fameux ces
fameuses déclarations
je crois que c'était étonnant pour
beaucoup des correspondants de voir la
france attaquée la commission européenne
parce que ma darling c'est une
commission européenne parce qu'il était
en train de faire son devoir son devoir
jamais on a eu le sentiment que c'est la
commission européenne qui attaque et la
france ici je peux pas parler pour tous
les gros respondents mais même le
sentiement le sédiment de journalistes
qui suivent les choses ici c'est plutôt
que la commission a le droit et le
devoir d'intervenir dont le toit
européenne n'est pas respectée et
d'oncle attaques personnelles à madame
reding mêmes l'atacama la holding com
comme citoyen luxembourgeois c'est
quelque chose qui était totalement mal
placé de la part du gouvernement
français
et sinon nos perceptions ici à bout
c'est d'ailleurs madame reding avait été
pressé par les valeurs européennes de
donner des réponses dans les cages il a
dit tout à l'heure donc il avait aussi
un devoir politique de réponse par
rapport à la confrontation qu'il avait
au parlement européen elle s'est sentie
trahie par certains affirmation qui
n'étaient pas ceux qui n'étaient pas
avec béridier à de la bad des ministres
français et elle a réagi comme ça et
c'est pour ça qu'on suit ya eu cette
réaction est ce que vous pourriez
comparer je dirais dans l'histoire
récente
ici à bruxelles ce qui se passe cette
crise entre un pays en l'occurrence la
france la commission européenne est ce
que est ce qu'il ya des précédents ce
que ça vous fait passer à des choses
dans le passé on sait très bien que avec
monsieur mouskouri le communiste italien
il y a eu des crises similaires
d'ailleurs ce monsieur qui a théorisé
l'idée que les commissaires ne doit pas
parler contre le gouvernement et surtout
pas leur peur parole de parler le
pantalon jean pas le droit de parler et
que c'est seulement le président de la
commission et son porte parole qui a le
droit de dire quelque chose
éventuellement de critiques par rapport
au gouvernement c'est une chose qui a
été théorisée par monsieur berlusconi
qui l'a demandé plusieurs fois
normalement il n'a pas été écouté par
des autres messieurs baroso ci a défendu
le rôle de la commission des sports
parole mais maintenant on voit que ça
fait tâche d'huile parce que
même le gouvernement français je dis pas
seulement mais c'est sarkozy parce qu'il
ya eu d'autres ministres qui sont
intervenus la non avec des
interrogations ont étonné ou par exemple
ont réfusé à la commission le droit le
devoir d'intervenir pour défendre le
douaron peine alors que c'est à dire
c'est que oui voilà c'est ce qu'écrit
dans les traités et les le gardien des
traités il doit le faire et d'ailleurs
je dois dire que moi j'avais été très
impressionné par la présidence française
mais c'est que monsieur sarkozy avait
fait pendant la présidence française a
été une des meilleures présidence des
dernières décennies je veux dire on l'a
vu avec la crise économique financière
on l'a vu avec la crise en géorgie
et avec cet épisode là sarkozy tombe de
saint bauzille européen n'existe plus
bon il line
il y a quand même quelque chose
d'incroyable
à voir le chef d'un pays qui est quand
même le pays des droits humains qui est
le pays qui a comme une responsabilité
morale politique culturelle en europe et
dans le monde où la défense des droits
humains faire ce qu'il sait c'est qu'il
a fait concernant les roms qui sont
quand même des citoyens européens et
canton qui se gagne européennes ont des
droits comme tous les autres citoyens
européens
quelles ont été les réactions en italie
puisque on sait que l'italie a tiré
confronté un peu au même problème et
apporter une solution qui s'en rapproche
comment ça a été vécu là il ya un
précédent en italie on le sait très bien
il y a
207 1 quand d'autres parlement européen
avant les élections il y a eu en italie
avec le gouvernement le nouveau nobel
dos chroniques qui venait d'être mise en
place
la tentative de démanteler des
campements rendent systématiquement dont
le surtout dans l'est dans les villes
majeures en italie et là il a eu le
parlement roumain qui est intervenue la
commission qui est intervenu et ils ont
réussi à changer au moins les parties
les plus contradictoires avec la loi
européenne qui était dont le décret et
dont les dents les mesures du
gouvernement
donc finalement cette action a été
éreinté un peu dans les règles
européennes avec un dialogue serré entre
la commission et l'italie est une vraie
montagne est finalement a dit vous voyez
ce n'était pas vrai que la commission
était contre nous quelque chose de
similaire
j'avais en france concernant cette
fameuse circulaire qui existaient et
après il n'existait plus après a été
changé donc on change les choses dans la
le cours des événements et après on dit
ah mais ça n'existait pas le parallèle
est là le la la taxe que la france a
fait à quel événement français a fait à
la commission
toutefois je crois que c'est quelque
chose de nouveau parce que on sait très
bien qu'il y à du qu'il y a des pulsions
populiste dans le bonhomme en italien
mais en france je n'avais pas encore vu
cette option pour une liste aussi forte
merci beaucoup lorenzo consoli alors que
faire que peut-on faire pour pour les
roms c'est l'une des questions que
kathia gilder posera dans un instant à
son invité qui est député européen roma
mais tout de suite
direction la roumanie justement où nous
allons voir sur place à quoi servent les
fonds européens qui sont décidés ici à
bruxelles
c'est un reportage à bucarest qui est
signée marie brémaud et mehdi shabana
à quelques mètres des boutiques et des
routes touristiques de la capitale
en plein coeur de bucarest la famille
tout cas qui squattent une maison
abandonnée
quinze personnes au total qui survivent
uniquement grâce aux maigres revenus de
nicoletta la mer occasionnellement femme
de ménage
on en a rien à faire de notre gueule
sans roumanie chez nous en ce manque de
nous et pourtant on est romain quand mon
fils va pour trouver du boulot je parle
pas de moi qui suis vieille rôle
embauche pas mon fils on voit qu'ils
exigent gagnent alors il ne le reçoivent
pas ici c'est la race qui compte
pourtant de l'argent et des aides il y
en a
les subventions européennes en faveur
des tsiganes se chiffrent en dizaines de
millions d'euros
lohengrin craignent à bénéficie de
financements européens pour notamment
mettre en oeuvre des projets d'insertion
professionnelle pour son président la
principale difficulté
la lourdeur administrative non par
l'état
le problème ne vient pas du tout du fait
du manque de ressources financières
potentiellement il ya des milliards qui
circulent sur le marché
le problème c'est plutôt la bureaucratie
mise en place par la roumanie
du coup peu de projets aboutissent et
les résultats en matière d'intégration
sur le marché du travail sont médiocres
45% des roms en roumanie sont au chômage
les formation professionnelle dispensée
par l'association apparaissent alors
dérisoire face à la situation
ça ne sert à rien que nous on forme cent
mille personnes rome grâce au fonds de
l'union européenne si au final il n'y a
pas de boulot
la crise économique facteur aggravant
pour les roms déjà victime de
discrimination la roumanie pays
particulièrement touché par la crise
des dizaines de commerçants ont dû
mettre la clé sous la porte
les chantiers tournent au ralenti gilles
havas bondit de bucarest quartier rome
christian 36 ans a suivi une formation
de cuisinier pendant trois mois grâce à
l' ong une prime ya mais du travail il
n'en a toujours pas je ne pense pas que
la situation va évoluer
la crise économique est terrible ça
concerne tout le monde
c'est donc encore plus difficile pour
les roms de s'intégrer sur le marché du
travail
récemment j'ai travaillé de semaine dans
un hôtel et un beau show ils m'ont dit
que j'avais volé un anorak en europe
chez au courage ça a été encore un
prétexte pour mettre à la porte the
apollo xi a classé les fois que
en 2009 à l'issue de la formation
quatre personnes sur 100 ont été
embauchés constantin fait partie des
plus chanceux
moi j'ai eu de la chance j'ai trouvé du
travail
peut-être que j'ai un atout à la
différence des autres
ma couleur de peau m'avantage et du coup
c'est cool chômage discrimination
pauvreté nombreux sont ceux qui
dénoncent l'inertie des autorités vous
même c'est le cas de william ouailles
vice-président du parti rome je dirais
que l'intérêt de la roumanie pour les
roms est purement formelle nos
dirigeants font semblant de soutenir les
politiques d'intégration car cela donne
une bonne image de la roumanie
ça joue en sa faveur sont entrés futur
dans l'espace schengen on a proposé à
différentes reprise d'intégrer les roms
à travers des programmes
c'est ce que nous disent les dirigeants
ce ne sont que des paroles
il
et retour à bruxelles dans cette
deuxième partie dans un peu d'eau avec
nous pour réagir à ce reportage
cristian preda bonjour alors vous êtes
députés européens venus de roumanie vous
parlez parfaitement le français puisque
en tout cas plutôt bien vous avez étudié
de nombreuses années en france il est
notamment le conseiller personnel du
président roumain basescu pour la
francophonie voilà comme ça on vous a
présenté
on voit avec ce reportage que votre pays
a tout de même un peu de mal à intégrer
la population rom
on s'en fiche de nous pourtant on est
roumain at on entendu dans ce reportage
qu'a fait la roumanie pourtant de tous
ces millions donnés depuis des années
par l'europe pour intégrer cette
population où est passé cet argent
pendant tout d'abord il faudrait que
malheureusement c'est pas simplement la
robe qui désole gouvernement le lot
ne nous est pas trop donc c'est vraiment
période de crise où il ya un
mécontentement qui est transmis dans
toutes les couches sociales dans toutes
les communautés donc c'est pas
simplement les roms
tchoubaïs il devait il ya des efforts
qui ont été faits y compris avec l'agent
de l'union européenne
il ya des actions du gouvernement qui
des gouvernements successifs ou ailleurs
qui ont été conçus blé certains domaines
le domaine de l'éducation par exemple
enfin c'est pas toujours c'est pas
toujours réussis mais bon c'est que le
gouvernement roumain a vraiment assumé
ses responsabilités ce qui n'a pas eu
une inertie il ya des petites choses qui
qui qui ont été faites et il faut le
reconnaître je crois parce que c'est
aussi intéressant pour pour d'autres
pays je crois par exemple le fait
d'intégrer ces communautés à partir de
leur langue donc
il ya des classes spéciales pour les
enfants roms où ils peuvent apprendre
dans leurs propres langues
c'est en allant passer d'une facilité
mais ça passe pas toujours parce qu'il
ya un taux d'abandon scolaire important
ainsi de suite
au niveau scolaire toujours si on parle
de l'université il ya des plaintes
spéciale donc il ya des gestes qui ont
été faites et bien aussi passé puisque
on reproche quand même alors on m'a dit
de ne pas utiliser à bon escient tout
cet argent donné par les fonds européens
tout à fait et ça se passe parce qu'il y
avait un mauvais accès d'une manière
générale au fonds européen et parce que
c'est vrai il y a des cet argent passe
plutôt dans le dans la zone des ong des
organisations non gouvernementales
et il se trouve que seulement une
vingtaine d'organisations pour un pays
de 20 millions pour une communauté rom
qui qui a peut-être 1.5 millions enfin
c'est le maximum donc une vingtaine
d'organisations c'est très peu donc il
ya dans l'exemple que vous avez présenté
c'est d'ailleurs une
une organisation que je connais mais
aussi l' agence en trône
il ya des organisations qui sont actifs
qui font qu'ils ont des projets
qui sont réussis il ya malheureusement
aussi l'incapacité d'accès s'effondre
donc à venir problème qui se pose c'est
justement de conçus dans des eaux plus
dans ce sens qu'elle va changer
justement en parlant de domaine g et des
associations qui oeuvrent sur place en
roumanie pour l'intégration des roms
certaines d'entre elles que vous
connaissez je crois d'ailleurs vous vous
reproche de ne pas avoir que la roumanie
elle n'a pas honoré ses engagements au
moment de l'entrée dans l'union
européenne du pays
écoutez cette question que vous pose
directement le directeur de l'ot njai
que nous avons rencontrés à bucarest en
2007 l'un des critères politiques pour
l'adhésion de la roumanie à l'union
européenne était l amélioration des
conditions de vie des roms en 2007 quand
la roumanie est devenue un état membre
on a donc considéré que ce critère
avaient été remplis par la roumanie
alors c'est pourquoi la commission et
certains états membres qui ont burhan
influence au sein du parlement européen
et dans les lions ont découvert trois et
un bras et l'adhésion que la roumanie
n'avait pas rempli ce finish c'est alors
justement pour répondre à cette question
en khl à la roumanie n'a pas honoré ses
engagements
écoutez quand elle est entrée elle avait
rempli ce que la commission lui avait
demandé il est vrai en même temps que
depuis quelques mois il ya des débats
autour de l'intégration des roms parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte ici ou là en
europe que cette communauté à des
difficultés c'est tout à fait
regrettable fait qu'on n'a pas pu
avancer plus je vais amener député
européen qui doit s'occuper en priorité
de ce dossier ce que c'est la commission
européenne est ce que c'est le parlement
est ce que ce sont les états vont
écouter chacun a des responsabilités moi
je trouve que bien sûr les gouvernements
nationaux sont sont impliqués pour les
citoyens roumains d'origine rom qui
vivra en roumanie bien sûr que notre
responsabilité la responsabilité du
gouvernement
non il ya aussi des responsabilités pour
les gouvernements ou les rondes se
trouve pour une plus brèves au plus
longue période c'est un c'est quand même
un choix celui de vivre de de vivre ici
ou là enfin tout citoyen européen était
quand de ce point de vue il n'ya pas de
différence je parle ça vous le comprenez
bien donc pour revenir juste très
brièvement sur sur la politique menée
par la france 2 depuis cet été
aujourd'hui vous vous l'a condamné à
l'image de certains de vos collègues qui
ont quand même pris des partis dans
l'hémicycle en disant que c'était
absolument jeu devant les condamnations
bon le condamnation ne vont pas faire
grand chose et c'est déjà passé déjà
fait les autres l'ont gêné le problème
c'est comment est ce qu'on peut
améliorer le sort de ces gens là alors
vous avez un niveau de député européen
si vous deviez faire déjà le fait de
dans la conscience de ce problème c'est
un pas en avant il ya un an quand on a
essayé moi j'étais parmi les initiateurs
de constituer un groupe au delà des
frontières politiques qui s'occupe des
roms on n'a pas eu de succès et donc
pourquoi je dis ça parce que le premier
baiser en selle pour cette communauté là
c'est le besoin de représentation
politique vous voyez il ya tellement
tellement
2 notamment ici au parlement européen
oui ici par exemple on a une seule
députée d'origine rom 1 sur les 700 son
6ème but est donc très peu il ya un
besoin de représentation politique comme
un besoin d'intervention sociale et donc
il y aura je suis convaincu et synergie
entre l'action des gouvernements
nationaux et l'action de la commission
parce que qui appartient en partie à
cette déraison la commission sera elle
aussi sur le terrain merci cristian
preda d'avant était avec nous pour cette
émission de rentrée de place à notre
nouvelle rubrique l'europe au bout du
fil vous avez des questions concrètes
sur l'europe est bien posé les par
téléphone ou sur le site internet europe
direct vous réponds et voici la question
de la semaine arrivé au standard
questions de thomas d'angoulême je suis
français et j'aimerais travailler en
allemagne pouvez vous me conseiller sur
la manière de m'y prendre
réponse bonjour toi donc en effet en
tant que citoyen français vous pouvez
tout à fait travailler en allemagne et
cela sans avoir besoin d'un permis de
travail
mais sachez aussi que la commission a
mis en place un réseau le réseau de
reste constitué de plus de 700
conseillers dans les états membres qui
sont là pour vous aider à trouver des
informations et on trouve des offres
d'emploi dans d'autres états membres
vous les trouverez notamment en france
dont le pôle emploi le plus proche de
chez vous voilà si vous voulez poser une
question faites le au 00 800 6 7 8 9 10
11 très facile à mémoriser en plus
l'appel est gratuit depuis un poste fixe
et c'est ainsi que se termine cette
émission se retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec françois beaudonnet à
bruxelles bonne site de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires
avant